[Music]
good evening goodbye it's an honor
really to be speaking to you from the
International Space Station when I look
out the window I can see planet Earth
but tiny blue marble in the dark
it seems so fragile anyone who has seen
this view will tell you that we are
citizens of one world all of the human
journey from the invention of the wheel
to the launch of the space station it
all happened on earth it our only home
and none of these giant leads who have
been possible without teachers space
missions our journey into tomorrow and
that is a voyage that teachers embark on
every day those teachers including our
top 10 finalists hitting on the space
this evening every day they beat
impossible odds every day they reach for
the stars so I'd like to be the first
person in history to thank all the
world's teachers from space now it is my
great privilege to announce the winner
of the global teacher prize 2017 the
winner of the global teacher prize 2017
is
Maggie McDonald congratulations Maggie
at least one today as well be earth I
give you of the Canadian Arctic where
you teach you should see how beautifully
the loops from 220 miles up and it's a
place that you're protecting by teaching
the next generation how they can take
care of it
Thank You Maggie and to all the world
teachers you all back home
[Music]